ce sont des monuments historiques devant
lesquels nous passons tous les jours des
vestiges de l'histoire comme le char du
gué trous 1
mais savons nous vraiment ce qu'il
représente j'ai toujours habité des
jours j'ai jamais lu la pancarte qui
était en dessous il a servi il a servi
oui il a servi exactement je sais pas
trop court parce que jamais eu
l'occasion d'aller m'approcher si vous
voulez alors pour remédier à cela la
ville a mis en place une carte
interactive grâce à des indicateurs de
couleur il sera possible de découvrir
les lieux emblématiques de la ville de
la guerre de 1870 jusqu'au conflit
algérien alors là on se trouve devant un
bâtiment qui a le bâtiment qui a abrité
la gestapo donc la police secrète d'état
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale un
bâtiment réquisitionné en août 1940 un
lieu de torture aujourd'hui quasiment
oublié par les dijonnais peut très bien
passer à côté sans se rendre compte
véritablement de ce qui a pu se passer à
l'intérieur de ses murs c'est
précisément pour lutter contre l'oubli
que la ville a pensé ce parcours
mémorielle qu'il s'agit de faire en
sorte que les dijonnais revivent leur
histoire et et puisse ainsi faire
revivre si ces parcours mémorielle un
travail important de collecte de données
d'une trentaine de sites sur ce tableau
la barricade érigée dans la rue jeannin
en octobre 1870 symbole de la résistance
des dijonnais à l'invasion prussienne
aujourd'hui il ne reste aucune trace de
cet événement et là encore l'application
sert à raviver la mémoire
ça m'a quand même qui est relativement
célèbre dans l'histoire de la ville mais
néanmoins il est certain que mon nombre
de dijonnais à qui vous poseraient la
question ne seront pas forcément qu'il
ya eu cet événement
dans dans la rue jeannin ce parcours
mémorielle doit s'étoffer dans les
prochains mois grâce aux contributions
des habitants cent dix monuments doivent
encore trouver leur place sur la carte
de la ville